[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum sportplatz dem
sport podcast des österreichischen
bundesheers heute zu gast im rollstuhl
tennisspieler nicolas langmann herzlich
willkommen
hallo dank für die einladung für alle
die uns jetzt nur hören und dich nicht
sehen
du sitzt im rollstuhl sie glauben dass
du einen unfall hatte ist wie du ein
ganz kleines kind warst erzähler mal was
ist genau passiert und warum sitzt im
rollstuhl
ich habe gehofft du sagst für alle die
uns nicht sehen er schaut verdammt gut
aus aber okay ich ja super jetzt komme
ich vom lustigen ein ernstes thema ich
habe genau ein autounfall zwei jahren
kam ich selber nicht daran erinnern ich
weiß nur das was mir meine eltern
erzählt haben wir hatten einen blöden
autounfall am weg zum einen großartigen
tirol wo schon jetzt große auswahl zu
wollen eben mein rückenmark beschädigt
wurde und ich bin seitdem sozusagen im
rollstuhl aufgewachsen kennt dann auch
selber nicht anders und glaubt das ist
ja sozusagen was dann optimal oder ein
sozusagen eine optimale voraussetzung
war dass alles zu verkraften oder halt
damit zu leben weil wenn man sich dann
das kennt kann man keinen vergleich
ziehen und wenn man dann relativ normal
aufwächst dann wird man gegen relativ
normal in dieser hinsicht gibt es
parallelen zwischen unseren geschichten
an sich hat ja auch als nicht ganz so
kleines kind den unfall und bin in dem
sind auch mit der behinderung
aufgewachsen sich verschweißt jetzt ganz
genau was du meinst aber ist erzählt mal
dein aufwachsen mit der behinderung weil
du gesagt hast du kennst das nicht
anders du hast es als normal empfunden
aber dann hast du sicher gemerkt wie gut
ich bewege mich anders von a nach b fort
wie bist du in diesen momenten dann
damit umgegangen wie ich damit umgehe
ist eigentlich nebensächlich war er
sozusagen wie man wie man umfällt
sozusagen auf das ganze reagiert mein
umfeld behalten zwei jahren meine
familie logischerweise es war irgendwie
relativ tragisch in österreich das war
also ich hatte mein unfall im jahr 1991
und damals gab es bis heute sachen nicht
sehr gute situation der kinder
rehabilitation
das heißt es gibt in österreich drei
zentren für gelähmte die sozusagen auf
die rehabilitation nach einem unfall
ausgerichtet sind da kommt man hin da
lernt man mit der behinderung umzugehen
nur war es so dass die auf kleinkinder
überhaupt nicht ausgerichtet sind und
wird zwar meine eltern sofort
entscheidung etwas was machen wir jetzt
wissen dass das aber nicht und dann
haben sie eine rehabilitation center in
moskau gefunden das uns aufgenommen hat
und wo ich mit meiner mama so neben dem
jahre 99 für sieben monate nach moskau
gezogen bin
und das war sehr russisch diese
rehabilitation das heißt das war nicht
das ziel okay wir versuchen jetzt ein
leben im angenehm zu gestalten und
versuchen als barrierefrei und und
halter barrierefrei zu gestalten sondern
deren ziel war okay wir geben diesen
jungen nicht zu viele barrieren wie
möglich und er muss halt lernen die zu
überwinden
ach es war sehr sehr hart ich bin damit
drei jahren gewesen die gewichte
gestemmt und sich dann ist es frische
bilder müssen vorstellt und meine eltern
sind diesen weg komplett gegangen nach
also ich habe prinzipiell sozusagen
immer alles selber überwinden müssen sie
haben zum beispiel mir zuhause verboten
hatte das klingt eine rollstuhl zu
verwenden dass ich 13 jahre alt war habe
ich zu hause in der wohnung habe ich
immer den rauscht über der tür stehen
lassen und bin dann am boden herum
gebracht hatten die saubersten bürger
nicht immer sagen auch die beste zeit
mit meiner hose und habe auch gelernt
wie man von a nach b ohne rollstuhl
konnten dass ich jetzt nicht an den
rollstuhl gebunden bin sondern dass ich
halt selber her auch sozusagen mobil bin
also wir hatten zum beispiel die
süßigkeiten schublade war auch bei
unserer kirche halt ganz oben und ich
habe mir dann halt wenn ich mal nicht
dabei und ich süßigkeiten läuft ach ich
sozusagen halt einen sessel genommen
habe den zum herd geschoben habe mich
vom boden auf den sessel gehoben
vorsätzlich auf den herd gesetzt und so
war ausgezeichnet
und da habe dann ebenso auch meine
toffifee und so durch welche
verrenkungen übungen nach bekommen ich
glaube dass das einfach daran mir
irgendwie zu diesem normalen und dankt
zeichen zugang ermöglicht hat weil ich
immer sehr lösungsorientiert weil glaube
ich und genau so was dann in der schule
ich will jetzt nicht zu sehr aus ich war
sozusagen nie dann in der schule
irgendwie repariert sondern immer sehr
gut inkludiert ich war mal ein gymnasium
war ich der einzige schüler mit
behinderung und waren genauso im
turnunterricht am fußballplatz war mit
den freunden in der freizeit am
fußballplatz ich war immer der
verteidiger
da sehr brutal dem stürmer rein gefahren
ist wahrscheinlich nur hautabschürfungen
also war auch relativ ineffizienten sie
sagen und so bin ich danach zum
deutschen spring gekommen also ich war
immer überall dabei habe immer irgendwie
halt meinen weg gefunden der aber dann
immer sozusagen ein ähnlicher weg
das ist das zeichnet sich auch aus wir
kommen auch gleich zum wirklichen
ursprung des tennis spielen wenn sie
jetzt eine retrospektive schaust wird
man wahrscheinlich pädagogischen nicht
mehr diesen weg wählen dass ich die dann
russischen noch ist dann nach sieben
monaten in moskau wirklich weisse
russisch gesprochen
also ich konnte ich konnte besser
russisch und deutsch aber hab das dann
natürlich in österreich ein kindergarten
bin leider verlernt werden noch bis zehn
zählen beweis für die zukunft kommt das
wieder auf war vielleicht nach einer
russischen impfung das kann dann muss
ich wieder aufflammt auf jeden fall
würdest du diesen weg genauso wieder
gehen also wie gesagt pädagogisch würde
man es wahrscheinlich jetzt anders
machen und man kann sich auch viele
dinge hinterfragen
aber das was bei dir dann übrig
geblieben ist dass du immer selber einen
weg findet dass du selber eine lösung
finden denkst du dass das auch damit zu
tun gehabt hat würdest du das noch mal
so machen wollen ja also ich glaube auch
dass ich meiner sportlichen karriere hat
sehr viel davon profitiert dass ich
einfach auch sehr schnell ein
körpergefühl bekommen aber ein sehr
aktives körpergefühl und als kind
sozusagen die möglichkeiten einer
behinderung immer ausgereizt habe ich
natürlich bin ich dann sozusagen auf dem
rollstuhl umgefallen weil ich ein ganz
schwieriges terrain mit wollte also
mitfahren wollte und physisch habe ich
sicher sehr davon profitiert wenn ich
jetzt noch mal kurz aus waldorfschule
war es schon so dass viel motivation
meiner eltern die in den 60er jahren auf
die welt gekommen sind und in einer zeit
aufgewachsen sind
wo menschen mit behinderung weggesperrt
wurden und nicht teil der gesellschaft
wahren und wenn
einzig mit behinderungen nichts zu tun
hat und wenn denen dann gesagt okay
jetzt zweijähriger sohn wird nicht
wieder laufen können war bei denen
sozusagen fiel dieser harten schule
wurde war die motivation dahinter wenn
wir ganz viel machen ganz viel
trainieren ganz viele therapien machen
und ganz viel probieren dass wir
vielleicht irgendwie das rückgängig
machen können also es war meine kindheit
sehr präsent das thema das ich halt
wieder gehen lernen soll
und das war so dass priorität nummer
eins aber ist unheilbar
war es schwierig aber es war sehr sehr
sicher ein tag als kind weg so 50
stunden therapie gemacht und die die
verrücktesten therapien sich vorstellen
kann es auch sehr viel in
alternativmedizinische sachen wir haben
da sehr viele wirklich gute auf der
ganzen welt besucht wo ich jetzt im
nachhinein ich sehr kritisch dazu stehen
es war sehr viel irgendwie verdrängung
nicht verdrängen und versuchen das
rückgängig zu machen
also das hat mich schon belastet weil
ich im endeffekt jeden tag aufs neue
halt meine eltern ein bisschen
enttäuscht weil er im ziel war halt
unbedingt dass ich wieder gehen kann und
ich kann sagen ich war das sozusagen
schon ein bisschen druck und schwierig
zu verarbeiten auf der anderen seite
dieses hatte unbedingt wieder versuchen
das geht haben auch wieder viel geholfen
und physischen bereich natürlich kann
man im nachhinein immer sagen so und so
was besser gewesen aber ich bin jetzt in
einem sehr guten punkt in meinem leben
eigentlich und einem sehr glücklichen
punkt auch dass ich so schlecht war es
nicht aber auch die aspekte dieser
angesprochen hast du hast du dann
irgendwann gemerkt was die wartungs
haltung ist und muss dafür dich selber
dann auch eine entscheidung treffen wie
du damit um geste gab es dafür nicht
einmal ein wendepunkt ja also ich glaube
in der pubertät vor allem beginnt man
irgendwie selber zu denken wenn das kind
macht man eben blinden nur das und da
war es für mich dann auch sozusagen die
ja das ist mein ziel okay ich will
wieder gehen und das macht man halt und
irgendwann stellt man sich die frage ob
jetzt da ich bin was ich vierter fünfter
klasse gymnasium hat einen coolen
freundeskreis tennis gespielt viel und
auf die weltraum geflogen auf turniere
und haben gedacht okay also ich hab
keine freunde ich muss ganz heraus
streichen auch ich habe einen älteren
bruder mit dem ich sozusagen die
kindheit und alle sehr sehr eng
miteinander alles gemacht haben und der
mich auch immer in seinem freundeskreis
mitgenommen hat und ich glaube da habe
ich ihm auch sehr viel akzeptanz einfach
erfahren und war ein halbwegs guter
schüler bestehen zumindest durchgemacht
und hatte eigentlich kurs leben und das
einzige was irgendwie also das große
wasser gefehlt dass ich diesen wunsch
nicht erfüllen kann und haben gedacht
okay wenn ich jetzt gehen könnte was
wäre anders
gut ich kein stufen rauf gehen aber da
helfen wenn meine freunde meistens und
ich habe nichts zu sagen diesen großen
sinn dahinter gesehen was jetzt mein
leben verändern würde wenn ich jetzt so
marschieren kann und von a nach b g weil
ich rolle hat jetzt von a nach b aber
das ergebnis ist das gleiche
und wenn ich mir halt immer wieder jeden
tag beweis dass ich scheitern daran
wieder gehen zu können und was nicht das
beste für die psyche gedacht okay ich
habe ich ein rollendes cooles leben und
bin damit auch sehr happy und es war
schwierig dass meine eltern irgendwann
ist es trotzdem etwas anderes weil die
halt doch sehr flach aufgegeben haben
für diesen traum und dann so zu sagen
hey die letzten 15 jahre die ganze
therapie war ich viel viel fisch ist
auch schwierig gewesen aber mittlerweile
merken sie schon dass das tabu show auch
im rollstuhl recht sein leben gemacht
hat das merken die habe ich alle das
auch gesagt dass du eben von a nach b
rolston stadt gehst du spielst auch
rolle sagt beschreibung ist super was du
genau macht er wirklich und du musst
auch rollen tennisspielen etwas gesagt
du bist immer mit einem bruder mit allen
dingen sie mit gegangen das alles mit
probiert so ist auch zum tennisspielen
gekommen warum ist dann aber
tennisspielen hängen geblieben also ich
habe begonnen wegen meinem bruder und er
hat immer mit meinem vater im urlaub
haben sie auf der tennis gespielt und
ich durch die bälle sammeln und das habe
er zu fahren gibt es auch einschlägig
mitspielen ob keine kugel getroffen hat
aber schon diesen spaß und ich glaube
das war sozusagen das was was mich dann
am tennis gehalten hat man hat dann ich
habe dann begonnen trainerstunden zu
nehmen und so was also ich weiß was 78
jahre alt
dann relativ schnell irgendwie so hin
und her gespielt und das waren also
richtige glücksmomente das ist sozusagen
das so hin und her spielen von hinten
ich meine was heute auf wirklich relativ
normales wasser so ein spaß also es war
dann vor allem einfach der spaß am sport
und dass er ein wirklich ehrgeiziges
kind werden sobald sie den matches
gekommen ist hat es mir dann gesagt und
ich habe relativ viel verloren am anfang
wollte ich mehr verlieren glaube ich
mehr trainiert und manipulieren auch
immer wieder aber es ist sozusagen die
motivation nicht zu verlieren und großer
spaß am sport wahrscheinlich die
kombination die das leistungs tennis bei
mir ausmacht und sie funktioniert du
bist erfolgreich du bist erfolgreichste
aktuelle ereignisse wie lange sowas
öfter bereich wird ich werde dich öfter
anrufen ich habe ich das du 2012 bei den
paralympics dabei warst aber nicht als
aktiver sportler sondern als teilnehmer
des jugendcamps des österreichischen das
große bewunderer von andrea sommer
das wäre dann das nächste gewitter
teilnehmer des jugendcamps und man hat
das schon gesagt der junge der er wird
der ist gut der hat ehrgeiz
du hast dort paralympics zum allerersten
mal erlebt was hat das in dir ausgelöst
einfach paralympics zu sehen da war ich
glaube dass london wirklich gute spiele
auch waren um sie zum ersten mal zu
sehen also das war unglaublich wie wenn
du weißt wahrscheinlich besser als ich
habe ich alles als an der zuschauerrolle
war einfach die ganze stadt war ein
paralympics fieber da waren so viele
leute überall bei jedem wettkampf egal
in welcher arena wir waren egal ob
zugeschaut haben es war überall eine
begeisterung da und da haben einfach
gemerkt wo es hingehen kann und ich
hätte mir liefert räumen können dass ich
meine so was im bieten sport überhaupt
gibt
ich meine nicht begonnen 1500 und ich
glaube 2008 bei peking habe ich das hat
unser halb verfolgt und habe gleich zehn
minuten zusammenfassung auf orf1
irgendwann gesehen über die paralympics
und 8
das ist es halt
und dass das dann so groß wird plötzlich
und allem was in rio von von uns
sozusagen was für ein medieninteresse
auch da war und wie viele leute damit
bekommen haben wie viele nachrichten
bekommen habe vor meine matches im
nachhinein nicht klug weil es
nachzulesen
das habe ich gar nicht nervös gemacht ja
das ist schon so dass so das
paralympische die paralympische wochen
sind einfach so unglaubliches
katastrophe schon den wunsch dass du
einmal bei den paralympics dabei bist du
hast das dann erst den londoner anstand
so richtig und so den wunsch engel hatte
ich ohne emotionale zugehörigkeit so
blöd es klingt also sozusagen natürlich
war soja paralympics jeder redet davon
wäre schon cool aber ich wusste nicht
was das ist wirklich und wenn das das
einmal gesehen zu haben hat dann schon
glaube ich noch mal einen boost gegeben
was der demonstration betrifft und auch
das training natürlich und du hast dann
für rio de janeiro 2016 sich zum ersten
mal auch für deine paralympics
qualifizieren können ich erinnere mich
dass das wieder gemeinsam unterwegs
waren das war natürlich eine große
freude mit dir und auch dass sich hat
sich noch an dieses der lehrerinnen in
zürich münchen geflogen ist und gleich
und 30 euro einen salat ist auch die
schattenseiten wenn man über zürich
behindertensportler hat uns das nicht
irgendwie ein cooler moment aber
sozusagen so dieses dieser dieser
vorspannung hatten wir beide nicht
wussten was kommt davon zuge wird rio
das war erst einmal zwölf stunden
flugerfahrung und nasa war war cool ich
spiele einfach ab so absolut sondern
brauchen wir vor allem ich habe nämlich
dass du mich am flughafen tennis erklärt
hast weil ich nicht wusste wie das
abläuft und dann selbst zu sehen wie du
während der spiele einfach einem prozess
durchlaufen was ich weiß ja dass selber
mitbekommen hast du hast jetzt auch
angesprochen dass du die ganzen
nachrichten gelesen hast und nervös
geworden bist es sportlich nicht so gut
gelaufen für dich 1 2 unterlagen völlig
komplette erste mal dabei auf jeden fall
aber ich habe gemerkt das tut er dann
dort die richtigen fragen gestellt hast
und auch die richtigen antworten
bekommen hast ich habe nämlich dass
dass ich beim doppel zugeschaut habe das
doppel zwischen den genres zu sein und
sagte ja weil ich dort war martin legner
dem langjährigen rollstuhl tennis
spieler langjährige nummer eins in
österreich
ich habe nämlich auch dass ich erst
gemerkt habe dass man beim tennisspielen
anscheinend nicht einfach frei jubelt
wie in einem fußballstadion weil ich als
einzige darüber herum geschrieben hat
sondern ich angefangen habe werden alle
anderen es gibt die etikett wir sind nur
besprochen
es war wieder so nicht bewusst auf jeden
fall diese veränderung die will ich
jetzt gerne ansprechen die jetzt bewusst
geworden dass spitzensport eben mehr
bedeutet als nur trainieren und
hinkommen sondern dass der viele
facetten mit dabei sind und nach rio gab
es auch dann die größte umfeld
veränderungen du bist nämlich ins
herzzentrum aufgenommen worden als einer
von den ersten fünf paralympischen
sportlern die inkludiert wurden in spa
zentrum wie war in rio der prozess und
dann nachher zu wissen okay jetzt kann
ich mich wirklich voll auf den sport
konzentrieren
ja ich glaube für mich wirklich so der
punkt wo ich begonnen habe
leistungssportler zu sein sonst hätte
ich wenn ich war dort nicht wie
qualifiziert was an sich schon richtig
cool ich war im 19
ich habe mir eigentlich nach der matura
ich meine frei genommen um nicht
wirklich eben voll auf den sport zu
konzentrieren aber wusste nicht wo
danach die reise hingehen einerseits
eigentlich durch die anstellung beim
bundesheer habe ich dann beschlossen
oder konnte ich dann überhaupt
beschließen dass ich weitermache weil
ich eben auch finanziell natürlich denn
es ist eine teure sportart muss trainer
bezahlen muss die flüge bezahlen muss
die hotels bezahlen und man fliegt zu
viel herum und die salate am flughafen
da sozusagen dass das dann alles sich
überhaupt ausging und dass man da diese
sind diese sicherheit hat eine
anstellung im hintergrund ist natürlich
großartig gewesen dass das dann gleich
auf vier jahre bis zur nächsten spielen
war relativ schnell klar wo die reise
hingeht und andererseits eben was
angesprochen dass der mentale aspekt in
rio war einfach ja da sozusagen ich
wusste überhaupt nicht was ich wusste
ist weil ich zugeschaut aber ich wusste
nicht was auch als sportler auf mich
zukommt was für große emotionen und
waren es war allein bei der
eröffnungsfeier
aber ich mich nicht wirklich drauf jetzt
eingestellt bzw
habe ich nicht gewusst was mich erwartet
wenn jack ma kanal und es waren relativ
viele von meinem familienmitgliedern und
mitgeflogen sind nach extra du hast mehr
fans als alle anderen
ja das recht cool das war richtig cool
richtig schön und dann steht man dann
eben ein dieses mal kanal steinig wir
müssen gemeinsam rein du weißt wie das
macht und wanderten zu sagen man hat das
publikum so halb gesehen und ich finde
wieder so ist raich vorne gesehen haben
60 meine familie und habe dann wirklich
sozusagen meine ganze familie und
freunde in den publikumsrennern gesehen
und ich bin zusammengebrochen gewann
zugleich eine hilfe ja das ist so cool
aber hat so viele emotionen die die die
nicht wirklich förderlich sind für einen
reinen focus am platz und habe dann das
sehr gut aufgearbeitet dann habe dann
mit meinen trainern sehr sehr sehr viel
an diesem mentalen aspekt unbearbeitet
und habe dann erst dann wirklich gelernt
diese ganzen emotionen im griff zu
bekommen und habe dann ab ende 2016
eigentlich unglaublich unglaublich
leistungsentwicklung gehabt wo ich dann
plötzlich so top 20 top 10 spieler also
substanz spieler geschlagen zu zehn
spieler fordern konnte wo ich halt
früher ganz weit weg war und dann
plötzlich war ich ende 1017 gleich top
20 plötzlich selber das war echt ein
nochmal 1 1 click effect das ist die
richtigen schritte gesetzt und sie haben
auch wirkungen gezeigt sportliche
entwicklung hast du genommen auch eine
menschliche entwicklung wie du genommen
hast die ich gerne beobachte und da auch
sehr wie video greift auch bist und und
dinge macht umgarnen und wir sehen kann
das alles jetzt nicht zu schauen ich
trage einen traumpass eine koroma frisur
auf jeden fall nächste qualifikation
paralympics ist so gut wie fix
tokio das heißt jetzt bist du mit all
diesen erfahrungen reicher du weißt ganz
genau was auf dich zukommt weiß ganz
genau was ich erwartet dass auch in der
zwischenzeit mutige entscheidungen
getroffen
möglichkeiten wahrgenommen die fast
einzigartig sind
du bist nämlich teil des teams sieht man
wie immer schwer zu du trainierst in
einer gruppe in der akademie von
wolfgang thiem bekannterweise der vater
von dominic thiem ich nehme mal an
dominic schaudt auch öfter vorbei wie
ist das wenn man als rollstuhl tennis
spieler also in einer gruppe ist mit den
besten spielern des landes die alle das
gleiche ziel haben nämlich performance
platz was konntest du von ihnen lernen
was konnten sie von dir lernen wie
funktioniert das jeder spricht sie an
das ist genau das was es ist endlich
weltweit einzigartiges wieder haben es
ist so dass eigentlich rollstuhl und
sozusagen dass ein rollstuhl tennis
spieler im gleichen umfeld wie ein etui
top profi trainiert ist wirklich
einzigartig und dass dieser ep top-profi
so nebenbei auch die nummer vier der
welt ist und grand slam sieger macht es
noch spezieller im sommer 2009 10 habe
ich eben im wolfgang irgend jemand
kontakt aufgenommen und wir haben so
über dem allgemeinen geräte und
allgemein tja ich bin eher mal gern so
zu sagen lass mich dich einmal anschauen
und nicht vorbei geschaut dann mache ein
paar trainings aktion machen das gleiche
zeit
seitdem ist eben der bach mit domenik
mein coach und das ist unglaublich weil
es sind die besten fünf österreichischen
tennis spieler dort im versammelt in
traiskirchen und ich und er ist es
sozusagen auch wieder das sehr enge was
zu meinem leben passt irgendwie dass da
auch überhaupt nötig gemacht aber das
ist halt das ist die österreichische
tennis elite und ich zähle mich jetzt
ganz recht dazu und an so dass einer von
den rollstuhl herum
denn es ist halb ennis und der
trainingseffekt oder trainingsaufwand
der trainings ehrgeiz muss ja auch immer
der gleiche sein und wenn ich da mal
nicht hundert prozent geht dann höre ich
das auch relativ lautstark das passiert
auch nichts aber es ist eben so dass das
überhaupt im kino tisch gemacht wird und
dass ich bin einfach vom vom zeichen
jahre einfach echt schön zu sehen dass
sport ist sport und ja deswegen freut
mich sehr dass das dass das ermöglicht
wurde
und weil sich das für jeden tag
so nutzen kann dass inklusion in dem sie
nach auf dieser ebene gelebt wird und
eben nicht nur auf den voerder ebene und
den strukturen davor sondern auch
wirklich im training selbst das auf
jeden fall ein ganz starkes zeichen und
man weiß ja auch die von dominik
verbindet auch eine freundschaft also
mittlerweile nicht nur eine trainings
partnerschaft und und das gemeinsame
sondern wirklich auch eine freundschaft
wie geht es da wenn du da mal ein gutes
turnier hast oder nicht so gutes turnier
und du kriegst eine nachricht zu wenig
und warte ich auf studierte ich frag
mich jeden tag ist einer der wenigen
wirklich jeden abend ich fühle mich
schlecht weil ich eine news open war
glaube ich und ich übrigens porto nie
gespielt ich glaube ich war ich gerade
semifinale gegen madoff gewannen die
ganze welt treffen also wie war es heute
im doppel das kannst du dich auf dich
selbst
also das ist schon echt cool dass es
einfach ich meine ja eben genau wir
sehen uns oft im training machen auch so
viel zusammen eigentlich reden wenig
eigentlich was tennis aber wenn dann
höre ich natürlich schon mit solchen
großen ohren zu weil es dann doch von
vom meister persönlich kommt sozusagen
also ich kann enorm viele natürlich von
den mitnehmen auch im einzel locker er
im alltag mit dem ganzen umgehen will
ich sicher ein sehr verkrampft sportler
bin was das betrifft ja irgendwie nicht
wirklich gut abschalten kann auch nicht
vom platz weg bin und sich an sehr
verkopft der menschenrechte ist um
einiges lässt sich ja eigentlich weil er
kann halt sehr gut umschalten
also im moment war auf den platz geht
ist 100% 100.000 prozent durch harte
arbeit aber es kann trotzdem auch
abschalten das ist eigentlich das was
ich sehr bewundert und umgekehrt er von
mir keine also technisch wieder gekocht
[Gelächter]
aber ja ich bin ein großer fan von
tennis muss ich sagen also eben zum
beispiel bei den grand slam turnieren
ist es so dass rollstuhltennis immer zur
gleichen zeit am gleichen ort im
stattfindet in mögen ganz in weiß aber
beim rauschen ist so dass nur die top
acht der welt teil
bei diesen großen turnieren und samuel
schwarz der die ganzen partien immer an
und schickt mir immer dann zum beispiel
bei den us open war schickte mir dann
immer dass er katar dann fragt mich
immer zu dem spieler wie der so ist und
recht kühl das einfach da die
wertschätzung so groß ist ist es dann
ich nehme auch deine richtung in die es
gehen soll grand slam die an ihre
partner ganz genau ich glaube wenn man
einmal diesem bereich erreicht hat dann
das ist das definierte ziel dabei zu
sein dass gleich das lebensziel von
jedem tennisspieler und das wäre dann
schon wenn ich das erreicht dann kann
ich nachts erkläre sagen gut was in
welchem zeithorizont nimmst du dir das
vor wie kann man das überhaupt in einer
so es ist schwierig wenn ich für
zeitarbeit und im tennis vor allem was
rankings betrifft kannst du eigentlich
dass jetzt mehr ungern weil die kannst
du uns selber wenig beeinflussen ich
setze meine ziele die meine leistung
betreffen das heißt einfach schlag
sicherheit schlag geschwindigkeit
fitness bizeps umfang
den kannst du deine salat oder schlecht
und dann sozusagen die ergebnisse
ergeben sich dann davon selbst ja
deswegen ich bin jetzt gerade 24
geworden und dennis sozusagen die nummer
eins der welt bei uns ist ein japaner 33
34 also ich habe schon noch ein bisschen
zeit vergangen das heißt dass noch
einige jahre vor die um diese ziele zu
erreichen
das was du jetzt gesagt das leben sie
auf die dinge zu konzentrieren die man
beeinflussen kann und so ein ranking ist
halt nicht aber auch allgemeine sachen
die passieren im leben auch das umfeld
das sich permanent verändert dass man
sich auf das konzentriert was man
beeinflussen kann das ist glaube ich
etwas wo sich jeder heute der zugeschaut
hat oder zugehört hat etwas mitnehmen
kann alle die zugeschaut haben die
wissen auch dass du wahnsinnig gut
ausschaut das ist auch mitbekommen
worden sein danach haben wir dann noch
mal neu gehört werden das jetzt noch
einmal pointiert auf jeden fall alles
gute für die zukunft
danke dass du da warst nicht eingereicht
und viel erfolg noch ich freue mich auch
drucke gemeinsam
ich denke dass wir auf jeden fall eine
spannende erfahrung und lustig davon
gehe ich aus danke auch dass ihr mit der
wieder beim sport reporter wir freuen
uns natürlich wenn ihr auch beim
nächsten mal wieder zuhört einschaltet
euch rein klickt bis nach
[Applaus]